[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Sievers in
allen guten Abend die Geduld des
bayerischen Ministerpräsidenten Markus
Söder wird gerade enorm strapaziert man
kann das förmlich miterleben am besten
noch heute forderte Söder dezidierte
Antworten seines Stellvertreters in der
Affäre um ein Flugblatt voller Judenhass
und Verhöhnung der Opfer des Holocaust
für Hubert Aiwanger steigt der Druck
sich umfassend zu erklären vor einer
halben Stunde heißt es dann die
Antworten aiwangers Antworten sind in
der Staatskanzlei eingegangen der Chef
der Freien Wähler in Bayern und so das
Koalitionspartner hatte heute noch mal
klar gemacht er fühlt sich als Opfer
einer Kampagne Zitat Aiwanger die Shoa
werde hier zu parteipolitischen Zielen
missbraucht
besondere Brisanz bekommt der Fall weil
in Bayern in fünf Wochen gewählt wird
Briefwahl geht jetzt bereits und weil
völlig unklar ist wie sich die Affäre
auf das Ergebnis niederschlägt Simon
Fanzelt berichtet
Bierzelt Wahlkampf in der
niederbayerischen Heimat
Hubert Aiwanger der Volkstribun das ist
die Botschaft
[Applaus]
bisher hatte er die flugblattaffäre im
Bierzelt ausgespart heute entdeckt
Hubert Aiwanger das Wahlkampfthema
Hubert awanger
[Musik]
in meiner Jugend scheiß gemacht jawohl
ich habe ein Mist gemacht und es gibt
viele Unterzähler mehr dazu die
vielleicht erst später noch Mist machen
aber meine Damen und Herren
gestern noch Bedauern und Entschuldigung
heute ist davon kaum noch was zu spüren
ihr wurde von langer
junger fertig zu machen mit dem Ziel die
Freien Wähler zu schwächen eventuell
sogar die Grünen in die Landesregierung
zu bringen das ist nicht unser Ziel hier
wurde versucht die Wahl gezielt zu
beeinflussen das ist eine Schweinerei
meine Damen und Herren
hier daheim lassen sie auf ihren
Aiwanger offensichtlich nichts kommen
Berichte über judenfeindliche Witze und
Hitlergruß ein antisemitisches Pamphlet
im Schulranzen alles nur Jugendzentrum
und wenn man dann noch 30 gehen und noch
gut dann ist es
so unmöglich also wenn der einwanger
Antisemit wäre dann war das aufgefallen
die letzten Jahre da war er in dem Amt
und tragbar muss eine ganz ehrlich sagen
aber ich sehe das so nicht weil es einer
von den besten Politiker in Bayern
obwohl dass ich noch nie gewählt habe
aber wir werden jetzt wählen ohne Hubert
wahrscheinlich nicht gehen
weil in Bayern ist einfach Hubert
einhorner ist einfach die freien WLAN
ob es auch ohne Aiwanger geht das fragt
er sich die Debatte um sein Vize
verhagelt Markus Söder den Wahlkampf er
will sich als zupackender Landesvater
inszenieren doch jetzt musste er auf
Antworten warten drei Tage lang am
Vormittag erhöht Söder den Druck für
mich ist wichtig dass die 25 Fragen
jetzt umfassen und glaubwürdig
beantwortet werden und zwar zeitnah und
zeitnah heißt am besten noch heute ähm
im Laufe des Tages so dass dann für mich
und die Entscheidung dich zu treffen
habe eine fairere abgewogene aber auch
glaubwürdige Entscheidung möglich ist am
Abend hat Aiwanger seine Antworten
abgegeben wie sie lauten noch nicht
bekannt doch er macht heute ohnehin
nicht den Eindruck als habe er vor
Söders Entscheidung Angst
denn seine Basis feiert ihn und es sieht
im Moment nicht so aus als könnte
irgendetwas das ändern
ein weiterer Bayer ist jetzt bei uns
erlebt in Würzburg ist dort als Notarzt
unterwegs aber vor allem Präsident des
Zentralrats der Juden in Deutschland
natürlich Josef Schuster herr Schuster
guten Abend
guten Abend Hubert Aiwanger ist ja auch
ihr Vize Ministerpräsident er hat sich
gestern entschuldigt insbesondere bei
den Opfern des NS-Regimes und deren
Nachkommen er hat das aber quasi unter
ein Vorbehalt gestellt und gesagt wenn
er Gefühle verletzt habe dann bereue er
das wie ist das bei Ihnen angekommen
also diesen Teil des Satzes habe ich
nicht als unangenehme empfunden wenn er
Gefühle verletzt hat ich finde es
problematischer das direkt in einem
Atemzug mit dieser Entschuldigung wieder
das Thema kommt dass er das ganze als
seine Kampagne gegen sich sieht ob das
in dem Zusammenhang der richtige Satz
war kann überdacht werden wissen Sie
denn eigentlich wofür genau sich
einfacher entschuldigt
also ich habe es so verstanden dass er
sich für das Pamphlet und insbesondere
den Inhalt dieses entschuldigt hat vor
dem aber sagt er habe es gar nicht
geschrieben
das sagt er so aber Fakt ist ja dass
dieses Pamphlet dieses Flugblatt in
seinem Rucksack in seiner Büchertasche
gefunden wurde also eine Verbindung zu
dieser Pamphlet scheint er doch wohl zu
haben denn selten fliegen Dinge von ganz
allein in ein Rucksack heute bezeichnet
sich einfacher jetzt als
Opfer in einem Interview der Welt in
seinen Augen werde die Zitat Shoa zu
parteipolitischen Zwecken missbraucht
kann man das so sehen
ich sehe es nicht so und was ich da aus
diesem Satz höre ist das was man unter
einer opfertäter umkehre steht dass also
jetzt versucht wird die Opfer zu Tätern
zu machen und das finde ich nicht sehr
gut
der Umgang allgemein mit den Vorwürfen
und die Affäre um das Flugplatz aus
ihrer Sicht welches Zeichen setzt das
denn insgesamt für Deutschland auch für
junge Leute in Deutschland ist das ein
Vorbild
ich glaube das ich hoffe nicht dass es
jemand als Vorbild sieht und was mich
ehrlicherweise am meisten erschüttert
ist sehr Umgang von Herrn Aiwanger mit
diesen Vorwürfen die er jetzt heute
genau eine Woche im Raum stehen von
deren er selber ja durch Fragen der
Presse schon einige Tage vorher wusste
dass er da nicht in der Lage war zum
Zeitpunkt der Erscheinen dieses Artikels
der Süddeutschen Zeitung sofort
entsprechende Erklärungen ausführliche
Erklärungen abzugeben wundert mich sehr
jetzt erleben wir aber Herr Schuster wie
die Freien Wähler ihren Chef feiern mit
sprech gehören sind sehr begeistert und
es gibt heute eine Umfrage danach sagen
klappt die Hälfte der Befragten für
schwere Verfehlungen in der Jugend
sollten Politiker nicht zur Rechenschaft
gezogen werden jetzt mal ganz unabhängig
wer der Urheber dieses Flugplatz war ist
das Flugblatt eine Jugendsünde
sie ist in der Jugend geschehen aber ich
würde sie nicht als Jugendsünde
bezeichnen das Problem ist auch nicht
dieses Flugplatz da Blatt das hier im
Raum steht wobei mich schon irritiert
der Bruder soll es geschrieben haben er
hat es im Rucksack ist ja doch ein
seltsames Umfeld in dem offensichtlicher
Aiwanger hier aufgewachsen ist aber es
geht doch viel mehr darum dass ich
erwartet hätte dass er sich sofort
umfassend hier von distanziert und das
hat schon recht lange gedauert bis er
sich gestern Abend zu dieser
Entschuldigung durchgerungen hat jetzt
ist ja vielleicht so dass manche unserer
Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer gar nicht
so genau wissen was in diesem Flugplatz
tatsächlich drin steht deswegen würde
ich gerne mal zwei drei Dinge daraus
zitieren auch wenn es sehr schwer fällt
da wird also ausgelobt ein Freiflug
durch den Schornstein in Auschwitz eine
Fahrkarte in die ewigen Jagdgründe
Erfüllungsort ebenfalls steht da das
Vergnügungsviertel Auschwitz und
Nebenlager
er Schuster das scheint sich ja jemand
doch mit dem Thema mit der Sache relativ
eingehend beschäftigt zu haben nur eben
auf unmenschliche Art
so ist es und was mich eigentlich auch
ja richtig schockt ist es gibt aus dem
Jahre 1900 jetzt 2019 die es gibt immer
vier Mal im Jahr so ein ja kleine
Drucksache der Freien Wähler das war
nach dem Attentat von Halle in dem in
diesem
Rundbrief der Freien Wähler ausdrücklich
auf das nie wieder das seit Ende des
Nationalsozialismus gilt hingewiesen
wird offensichtlich war das auch zu
diesem Zeitpunkt 2019 oder beim
Geschehen dieses in den 80er Jahren noch
nicht bei allen angekommen jetzt
Bestreiter der Autor gewesen zu sein
sein Umgang wir haben sie mehrfach hier
besprochen mit der Affäre lässt viele
Fragen offen wenn jetzt aber genau das
ihm in Bayern einen Wahlsieg bescheren
sollte Geräte generell in Deutschland
etwas ins Rutschen bei uns
ich würde sagen nicht ist Gerät nicht
etwas ins Rutschen aber wenn das so
einem positiven Wahlerfolg führt ein
solches Blatt dann irritiert mich das in
höchstem Maße und zeigt natürlich das
offensichtlich was ich nicht gedacht
hätte mit der Aufarbeitung der
Geschichte des Nationalsozialismus doch
mehr im eigenen ist als viele vermuten
und was müsste dann jetzt passieren in
dieser Sache und vielleicht auch darüber
hinaus womit wäre der besonderen
deutschen Erinnerungskultur am besten
gedient
nun wir sind nicht schlecht in der
Erinnerungskultur und ich begrüße das
auch ausdrücklich und es betrifft ja
nicht alle die nicht alles so ganz
mitbekommen aber man muss sich wirklich
Gedanken machen wie man das doch noch
intensivieren kann und es spricht ganz
klar dafür dass diejenigen die sagen
Schlussstrich ziehen genau auf dem
Holzweg sind sagt der Präsident des
Zentralrats der Juden in Deutschland
herr Schuster herzlichen Dank für das
Gespräch
gerne
aus Termin Gründen am späten Nachmittag
aufgezeichnet
so jetzt hier in der Sendung unser
nächstes Thema egal wie lange her viele
von ihnen können sich vermutlich noch an
ihren ersten Schultag erinnern an die
Vorfreude die Schultüte die Erwartung
und vielleicht auch das Bangen was da
jetzt kommen wird
den meisten der 340.000 Erstklässler in
der Ukraine wird ihr erster Schultag
heute noch aus anderen Gründen im
Gedächtnis bleiben weil es immer noch
ein Schulanfang im Krieg ist weil es
Klassenzimmer gibt die zerstört sind und
Unterricht mancherorts in der U-Bahn
stattfindet weil zur Schulglocke die sie
reden kommen aber auch weil Schule Ihnen
so etwas wie Routine und Sicherheit
vermittelt nebenlesen schreiben rechnen
sie schießen Fotos wie sie überall
gemacht werden denn für Kinder der Ernst
des Lebens beginnt
doch in saporicia wurde es für die
Kleinen schon lange vor dem ersten
Schultag ernst für ihre Eltern sowieso
und so haben Sie sich einfach über alle
Sicherheitsbedenken hinweggesetzt und
ihre Kinder zur Einschulung gebracht
wissend dass sie jederzeit eine
russische Rakete einschlagen kann
wofür sollen wir denn Angst haben wir
haben ein einziges Leben wir leben jeden
Tag als wäre es der letzte wir sind
dankbar für jeden Moment und so haben
wir keine Angst
der Schultag ihrer kleinen wird ab
Montag trotzdem so aussehen die Lehrerin
unterrichtet vor lauter Kuscheltieren
die Kinder begrüßt sie auf ihrem Laptop
in der Ukraine beginnt für knapp vier
Millionen Schülerinnen und Schüler nach
den Ferien der Unterricht wieder mitten
im Krieg landesweit lernt jedes vierte
im distanzunterricht in saporisiere
sogar alle
wir haben seit Kriegsbeginn gute
Erfahrungen mit Online-Unterricht
gemacht und wir haben auch viel gelernt
auch wie wir mit unseren Emotionen
umgehen müssen
Emotionen die auch aufkommen wenn
draußen plötzlich die Sirenen heulen
Lehrerinnen und Reporter müssen in den
Bunker der Schule zu Hause verlässt Ilja
seinen Rechner und geht mit seiner
Mutters wird Lana im Flur Entdeckung für
beide ein gut geübtes Ritual billiger
würde aber lieber in der Schule lernen
als zu Hause
in der Schule gehen wir bei Luftalarm in
den Bunker dort gibt es schultische und
wir können weiter lernen
das ist der Schulbehörde jetzt zu
riskant die mutigen Eltern von saporicia
akzeptieren Zähneknirschen dass ihre
Kinder noch lange nicht neben ihren
neuen Klassenkameraden sitzen werden
im Moment gibt es keine Wahl das ist
jetzt eben so ich denke im Prinzip
klappt das auch alles ganz gut aber wir
warten wirklich darauf dass es wieder
Präsenzunterricht gibt wir warten
wirklich
dabei ist der distanzunterricht für
viele längst zur Regel geworden man wie
besucht Abschlussklasse 11 und lernt
jetzt wegen Corona und Krieg im fünften
Schuljahr von zu Hause er kann sich
regulären Unterricht kaum noch
vorstellen
es ist viel einfacher gute Noten zu
schreiben auch wenn man weniger lernt
als man eigentlich soll denn der
Unterricht wird der kommt kontrolliert
und so zählt mehr und mehr auch das
ukrainische Schulsystem zu den
Verlierern von Russlands Angriffskrieg
sie haben sich alle schicke macht zum
Schulanfang im Krieg und wir bleiben
noch beim Thema mit Johanna Moskau hat
zahlreiche ukrainische Drohnen Angriffe
auf das russische Territorium gemeldet
in der Nacht soll unter anderem die
russische Stadt Kurt scharthoff
angegriffen worden sein und auch der
Moskauer Bürgermeister meldete einen
Drohnen Angriff der abgefangen worden
sei unterdessen startete Russland
gemeinsam mit verbündeten ein
Militärmanöver im Westen von Belarus mit
mehr als 2000 Soldaten an den Übungen
die bis Mittwoch dauern sollen nehmen
auch Truppen aus Kirgisistan und
kasachstanteil
die Bundestagsfraktion der Union hat
ihre zweitägige Klausur beendet mit
deutlicher Kritik an der Politik der
ampelregierung und einem
Forderungskatalog um die Wirtschaft
anzukurbeln so will die Union unter
anderem die Sozialabgaben bei 40%
Deckeln über Stunden und arbeiten im
Rentenalter steuerfrei machen die
Gesamtsteuerbelastung von Unternehmen
bei 25% Deckeln und Bürokratie abbauen
auch die AFD war in Klausur und hat ein
Sofortprogramm für den Fall einer
Regierungsübernahme bei der nächsten
Bundestagswahl vorgelegt das
Maßnahmenpaket umfasst zehn Punkte vor
allem zur Energie- und Migrationspolitik
unter anderem sollen die CO2-Abgabe
ersatzlos gestrichen und Energie Steuern
gesenkt werden zudem will die Partei
Nord Stream 2 reparieren und wieder in
Betrieb nehmen und
Atomkraftwerke wieder ans Netz nehmen
mit Blick auf illegale Zuwanderung will
die AFD den Grenzschutz stärken und
konsequenter abschieben
das deutschlandticket hat tausende
Neukunden in Busse und Bahnen gelockt
laut einer bundesweiten Umfrage des
Verbands deutscher Verkehrsunternehmen
gaben acht Prozent der Ticketkäufer an
vorher nicht mit dem öffentlichen
Nahverkehr gefahren zu sein fast jeder
zweite Nutzer des deutschlandtickets vor
bereits vorher mit Bus und Bahn
allerdings ohne ein Abo
vor 75 Jahren trat zum ersten Mal der
Parlamentarische Rat zusammen auf den
das Grundgesetz zurückgeht heute
erinnerten daran die Spitzen der
deutschen Verfassungsorgane beim Festakt
im naturkundlichen Museum Bonn rief
Kanzler Scholz dazu auf die deutsche
Verfassung zu schützen
Bundestagspräsidentin Bars hob die
enorme Bedeutung der Grundrechte hervor
der parlamentarische Radtag davon 1948
bis 1949 als verfassungsgebende
Versammlung deren 65 Mitglieder das
Grundgesetz für einen neuen
westdeutschen Staat ausarbeiteten
Dauerthema in der politischen Diskussion
bei uns und natürlich noch mal besonders
in den gerade laufenden Wahlkämpfen etwa
in Hessen ist die Flüchtlingspolitik
während die Debatte läuft wird die
Herausforderung nicht weniger im
Gegenteil seit Beginn des Jahres haben
so viele Migranten versucht illegal in
die EU einzureisen wie seit 2016 nicht
mehr allein über die Mittelmeerroute
registrieren Europas Grenzschützer mehr
als doppelt so viele Menschen wie im
Vorjahr und für über 2000 von ihnen
wurde das Mittelmeer in diesem Jahr
bereits zum Grab
wegen der Situation in Deutschland
schlagen die Landkreise schon länger
Alarm sie sind es die vor Ort die
Unterbringung organisieren müssen
Susanna Santina berichtet
diese Zelte im hessischen Bensheim war
noch Anfang des Jahres mit fast 1000
geflüchteten komplett belegt
mittlerweile leben nur noch rund 270
Menschen hier weiterhin vor allem junge
Männer aus Syrien Afghanistan und der
Türkei viele konnten zwischenzeitlich an
die Kommunen verteilt werden sagt
Matthias schimpft der Kreis Beigeordnete
eine Entwarnung sei das aber noch lange
nicht
ein trügerischer Schein das Land Hessen
hat mitgeteilt dass ab September wieder
mit erhöhten Zuweisung deutlich erhöhten
Zuweisung zu helfen ist und dadurch dass
wir noch sehr sehr viele Menschen
zusätzlich bekommen während Perspektive
schwierig ist ob sie hier bleiben
gelingt im Grunde Integration nach wie
vor nicht die Lage ist keineswegs
entspannt das spüren auch die
geflüchteten hier diese Männer kommen
aus Syrien als wir mit Ihnen sprechen
kommen immer mehr dazu jeder will und
seine Geschichte erzählen alle seien
illegal eingereist sagen sie hätten
einen Schleuser bezahlt der Susi 7000$
seine Frau und Kinder will er so bald
wie möglich nachholen
ich bin ein guter Fliesenleger habe viel
Erfahrung aber ich muss erstmal Deutsch
lernen
Deutschland Janik allem Unterricht
denn Sprachkurse sind wahr und da der
Asylantrag des Syrers noch nicht
anerkannt wurde sieht es mit Arbeiten
ohnehin schlecht aus
amaduri ist als Asylant bereits
anerkannt er ist seit Februar in
Deutschland der Vater von drei Kindern
ist ein Gegner von autokrath Assad Flo
aus dem Militärdienst
anerkannt haben ich will arbeiten und
eine Wohnung suchen ich wünsche mir ein
schönes Leben für meine Familie und
meine Kinder
Unterlagen ich hoffe dass ich dann bald
eine Arbeitserlaubnis bekomme ich bin
Maler
viele erzählen uns dass sie Deutschland
doch deswegen wählten weil sie gehört
hätten dass er Familiennachzug hier
einfacher sei als in anderen Ländern und
natürlich weil Deutschland ein
Rechtsstaat sei
viele Kommunen echzen aber unter der
Last der vielen geflüchteten und die für
September erneut erwarteten hohen
Zuweisungen machen vielen sorgen nicht
nur wegen fehlendem Wohnraum
auch in seiner Gemeinde sei man am Limit
sagt Volker ölenschläger der
Bürgermeister von Fürth ein Integration
sei nicht zu denken
was bedeutet integration bedeutet ein
anderer Menschen kennenlernen bedeutet
vor allen Dingen arbeiten und in Bildung
zu kommen es ist wichtig dass wir die
Menschen an die Hand nehmen Sprache
beibringen und dann schnellstmöglichen
Arbeit bringen und das sind wir ja im
Vergleich zu anderen Ländern relativ
schlecht aufgestellt das heißt es dauert
sehr sehr lange bis diese Menschen bei
uns in lohnen Brot sind ein wichtiges
Mittel der Integration ist auch
geflüchtete Kinder so schnell wie
möglich in den Kindergarten zu bringen
jeder Platz kostet die Gemeinde
monatlich mehr als 1000 €. abgesehen
davon dass auch hier Plätze fehlen und
solche Container Wohnungen tragen auch
nicht zu Integration bei viele die die
zeitunterkunft in Bensheim nach vielen
Monaten verlassen konnten sind nun hier
untergebracht wie lange kann keiner
sagen
Asylverfahren finden in den Erstaufnahme
Ländern statt nach EU-Recht sollte die
Bundesrepublik also eigentlich gar nicht
zuständig sein dass sie ja geographisch
mittendrin liegt dennoch werden rund ein
Viertel aller eu-asylanträge in
Deutschland gestellt allein das zeigt
bereits die Lücken der europäischen
Asylpolitik manche sagen ihr Scheitern
Europa ist hin und hergerissen zwischen
den politischen Willen die Migration in
den Griff zu bekommen indem die Zahlen
sinken und den Heeren Werten einer
demokratischen Union Florian neuhahn und
ultra
in Europas Hauptstadt Brüssel campieren
sie längst auf dem Straßen es sind so
viele die Stadt ist so überfordert
Plätze in Notunterkünften soll es ab
sofort nur noch für Frauen und Kinder
geben Brüssel ist nur ein Beispiel von
vielen Krefeld in NRW auch hier fürchtet
der Bürgermeister bald wieder Turnhallen
für Flüchtlinge statt für den Schulsport
nutzen zu müssen
in Krefeld sind für eine sehr tolerante
Stadt und die Akzeptanz ist an sich gut
aber je mehr ich Leistungen für
Krefelderinnen und Krefelder
einschränken muss bei gleichzeitig
größerem Zuzug von geflüchteten führt
das natürlich ganz automatisch dazu dass
die Akzeptanz sinkt Europa fürchtet um
seinen sozialen Frieden davor dass die
Demokratie von innen in Gefahr gerät
Europas Lösung ist neue Härte
Abschiebungen und Zäune statt
Willkommenskultur österreich hat so im
ersten Halbjahr bereits die Zahlen
gedrückt der Innenminister will nur noch
jene reinlassen die wirklich vor Krieg
und Verfolgung fliehen
aber das können wir nur wenn wir auch
Platz haben für Sie weil das System
nicht durch jene belastet wird die das
System missbrauchen diesen müssen wir
ein Regelfall schieben wir selbst in
Bedrängnis ist kann nicht nur mit
vorzeigedemokratien zusammenarbeiten
Tunesiens Präsident umworben von der EU
im Juli verspricht die
eu-kommissionspräsidentin Geld damit er
die Flüchtlinge daran hindert weiter
nach Europa zu ziehen dieselbe Erwartung
diese Woche vom Chef der EVP
Partnerschaft muss im Mittelpunkt stehen
und da können wir uns die Partner die
wir haben nicht aussuchen wir müssen mit
denen Arbeiten die wir haben klar ist
aber Tunesien muss liefern Europa hat in
der Flüchtlingspolitik lange nicht
geliefert zugelassen dass tausende im
Mittelmeer ertranken an moralischer
Bankrott jetzt setzen die EU-Regierungen
auf Abschreckung wollen einen Großteil
der Flüchtlinge schon an den
Außengrenzen stoppen doch der Kompromiss
in die deutsche SPD Innenministerin als
historisch feiert muss ab nächster Woche
doch mit dem Europaparlament verhandelt
werden und hier warnen nicht nur die
eigenen Genossen vor einer Aushöhlung
des Asylrechts die Verhandlungsposition
des Rates achtet zumindest nicht voll
umfänglich dass Asylrecht auf das wir
uns in Europa auch und auch
international verständigt haben wir
sehen ja vor allem ein Wettbewerb der
Unwürdigkeit viele EU-Staaten versuchen
die Menschen so schlecht zu behandeln
dass sie möglichst schnell weiter ziehen
und so kann EU Asylpolitik nicht laufen
es geht um das Schicksal der Flüchtlinge
aber auch um die Frage wie belastbar der
Kontinent noch ist in wenigen Monaten
wird in Europa gewählt bis dahin will
die EU endlich eine Antwort finden aber
schon jetzt sind die Verhandlungspartner
gereizt da dürfen wir diese Diskussion
nicht mit schauen vom Mund führen das
ist ganz wichtig weder von der linken
Seite noch von der richtigen rechten
Seite es geht um meinen pragmatischen
Weg der Vernunft dass wir die Systeme
entlasten entlasten und dabei einen
freundliches Gesicht zeigen das ist
Europas neuer ballonsakt
so jetzt in der Sendung noch mal du
Hannah mit einem Krimi bei dem man echt
auftaucht ja es geht definitiv um einen
besonderen Teil von
Wirtschaftskriminalität der Hamburger
kupferhersteller Aurubis hat bei einer
laufenden Inventur festgestellt dass ihm
große Mengen Metalle Fehlen der Schaden
wird auf mehr als 100 Millionen Euro
geschätzt und Frank Bethmann bereits im
Juni berichtete der Konzern von einem
Millionen schweren metalldiebstahl
dieses Mal sind die Täter aber offenbar
anders vorgegangen was ist bisher
bekannt sie haben gewissermaßen eine
Schwachstelle im Recyclingsystem
ausgenutzt Aurubis verdient sein Geld in
dem es wertvolle Elektronik und anderen
Schrott ankauft und daraus Kupfer Gold
Silber Platin generiert zentral dabei
aarubis prüft bei der Anlieferung
stichprobenartig wie viel der Schrott
wert ist und hier können nun entweder
die Stichproben gefälscht gewesen sein
also Täuschung der Schrott in der
Stichprobe enthält beispielsweise mehr
Edelmetall ist wertvoller als der ganze
Rest oder um einen unternehmensprecher
zu zitieren man prüfe auch inwieweit
interne Täter involviert waren also kann
es sein dass eigene Mitarbeiter dem
Unternehmen bewusst geschadet haben
auch an der Börse notiert solche Wellen
hat das heute auf dem Parkett geschlagen
ja hohe sehr hohe Aurubis musste eine
Gewinnwarnung rausgeben klar dass man so
etwas hier gar nicht gerne hört gleich
am Morgen Stürze das Papier um über 18
Prozent ab am Abend dann immerhin noch
ein Minus von gut 6 Prozent zum zweiten
Mal in diesem Jahr wurde nun bekannt
dass das Hamburger Unternehmen Opfer
krimineller Machenschaften geworden ist
ein erheblicher Schaden nicht nur in der
Bilanz sondern auch fürs Firmen Image
vielen Dank Frank für diese Einordnungen
durch Datendiebstahl Spionage und
Sabotage entstehen der deutschen
Wirtschaft jedes Jahr Schäden von mehr
als 200 Milliarden Euro den Großteil
davon machen Cyber-Attacken aus das
zeigt eine Umfrage des Branchenverbands
BITKOM immer mehr Angriffe kommen
demnach aus Russland und China der
organisierten Kriminalität werden 61%
der Attacken zugeschrieben ein neuer
Höchstwert
die IFA in Berlin die nach eigenen
Angaben weltgrößte Messe für
Unterhaltungselektronik und
Haushaltstechnik ist seit heute für
Privatbesucher geöffnet mehr als 2000
Aussteller aus 48 Ländern präsentieren
ihre technischen Neuheiten erwartet
werden bis einschließlich Dienstag
180.000 Besucher
Schwerpunktthemen sind künstliche
Intelligenz und neue
nachhaltigkeitslösungen nach
Umsatzeinbrüchen hofft die Branche nun
wieder auf Normalisierung
einer der teuersten Transfers der
Bundesliga könnte nun doch klappen der
Eintracht Frankfurt Stürmer kolonyani
soll nach übereinstimmenden Medien
berichten nun doch zu Paris
Saint-Germain wechseln am frühen Abend
hatte es noch geheißen der 24-Jährige
bleibe in Frankfurt PSG soll den
Berichten zufolge dass bisherige Angebot
von rund 90 Millionen Euro noch mal
erhöht haben eine Bestätigung der
Vereine steht noch aus
die deutschen Basketballer haben bei der
WM in Asien ihren Siegeszug fortgesetzt
und außerdem vorzeitig einen wichtigen
Teilerfolg in der Tasche die Mannschaft
von Bundestrainer Herbert gewann mit 100
zu 73 gegen Georgien ist der 4 Sieg im
vierten WM Spiel und bei Slowenien heute
ebenfalls gewann hat das deutsche Team
sein Ticket fürs Viertelfinale bereits
sicher
ja diese E-Roller zum Ausleihen kennen
sie sind in vielen Städten ja eine
schnelle Alternative für kurze
Fahrstrecken sie sind aber auch ein
Problem das heißt die Benutzer sind ein
Problem die ihre Roller mitten auf dem
Bürgersteig abstellen oder ins Gebüsch
werfen oder denken es sei eine gute Idee
zu dritt in Schlangenlinien durch die
Fußgängerzone zu rumpeln Paris war die
erste europäische Großstadt in der mit
Roller großflächig eingeführt wurden
mit dem heutigen Tag ist damit wieder
Schluss die Stadtverwaltung verbannt die
leih-roller von den Straßen die
Betreiberfirmen müssen jetzt tausende
davon einsammeln und haben bereits eine
Idee was mit denen geschieht
sie werden künftig zum großen Teil in
Berlin zu finden sein und dann
hoffentlich nicht im Landwehrkanal
so damit sagen wir zwei im Namen des
gesamten Teams danke für heute gleich
nach uns ein heute show Spezial und
gegen 020 dann unser heute schon mal
Update
mit Kindern
[Musik]
guten Abend spätestens am Sonntag
dominiert bei uns ein Hoch genauer ist
es sogar eine Hochdruck Brücke nämlich
ein Hof von den Azoren dass ich mit
einem hoch über Mitteleuropa verbindet
jetzt allerdings haben wir es noch mit
den Resten einer Warmfront zu tun und so
wird es heute Nacht hier in Thüringen
und in Sachsen noch etwas regnen und im
besten sind einige Regenschauer
unterwegs sonst ist es auch mal klar und
dann bildet sich Nebel und die
Temperaturen sinken auf 15 bis 8 Grad
morgen liegen die Höchsttemperaturen bei
21 Grad an den Küsten von Nord und
Ostsee und maximal 30 Grad am Oberrhein
in Norddeutschland wird das morgen ein
freundlicher Tag sondern Wolken wechseln
sich ab und auch in Süddeutschland
scheint die Sonne zum Teil strahlt in
der Mitte aber halten sich noch die
Reste der Warmfront von heute da gibt's
noch Regenfälle und in den westlichen
Mittelgebirgen sind auch Gewitter dabei
am Sonntag beschränken sich diese
Gewitter hier auf Niederbayern sonst
wechseln Sonne und Wolken miteinander ab
bei 20 bis 29 Grad und die neue Woche
startet sehr spät sommerlich sonnig bei
Höchsttemperaturen von 20 bis 31 Grad
und das ist über drei Tage so viel
Sonnenschein gibt das liegt an einem
kräftigen hoch es ist nicht nur ein ganz
normales hoch sondern wir sprechen in
diesem Fall von einer Omega Wetterlage
ein hoch das flankiert wird von Tiefs
und das sieht dann so ähnlich aus wie
der griechische Großbuchstabe Omega
vielleicht entwickelt sich hier bei dem
westlichen Mittel mehr sogar ein kleiner
medical eine Hurrican ähnliche Struktur
wir warten es ab und Abend